it could start with an accident someone
hits your car on the way to work at the
hospital you get a prescription for the
pain
you take the painkillers for a few weeks
like the doctor orders but when your
prescription runs out the pain is still
there so you get a refill a higher dose
this time you notice that when you miss
a pill you feel really terrible nauseous
you have sweats and cramps you need the
medication to feel normal
so you ask for another refill and
another but it's not enough you realize
you might have a problem but you can't
talk about it
what would your co-workers say how would
your family react you try to keep it a
secret but things start to fall apart
around you you need the relief this is
not an isolated problem
drug overdose is the leading cause of
accidental death in the u.s. a class of
drugs called opioids is driving this
epidemic this includes prescription
painkillers and also heroin four out of
every 5 new heroin users started out
misusing painkillers in 2014
1.9 million people were addicted to
painkillers and another 500,000 were
addicted to heroin from 1999 to 2014
opioids and heroin killed a quarter of a
million Americans 78 Americans died of
opioid overdoses every day so how did
this problem get so massive in the past
opioids were only given to cancer
patients on the terminally ill because
they were recognized as dangerously
addictive but in the mid 90s a
pharmaceutical company introduced a new
opioid painkiller which they claimed was
less addictive the prescription of
opioid painkillers soon exploded and
addiction rates skyrocketed in 2012
alone 259 million painkiller
prescriptions were written suddenly a
massive group of people were being
exposed to highly addictive drugs they
otherwise would not have sought out and
while sales for the drug soared
there was little training for doctors on
how to recognize addiction or minimize
withdrawal there have been a lot of
lawsuits against some of the companies
that manufacture these drugs in 2007 a
federal investigation found the maker of
the popular painkiller oxycotin
downplayed its risk of addiction the
company was ordered to pay 635 million
dollars but the drug is still on the
market
so how do you stop an epidemic when
addictive drugs are being marketed as
the key to less pain